this is just yeah this is super
different to what the Alpha look like so
props to the team it looks really really
good ooh flashbacks so that's a
flashback I wonder if that's how all of
the story's gonna be told I'm just gonna
turn subtitles on for all of you guys
small outline medium outline I guess
well how are there so many options
that's crazy
I can't lockpick it ah I see
I'm gonna need a key card to get into
this business but I don't have safety
goggles Oh Oh got someone's diary just
ashes something in it two umbrellas and
not-so-jolly prolly G move now I have a
Brawley stop oh that's gonna be okay I
feel like that what ah how did that
scare me so much that terrified me I did
not expect that is this is this what
jump scares aw oh he actually has a lot
of health what a jerk I guess that's my
stab and it was what I was thinking was
his health spa I can't risk any yeah
real sorry about that jump scare
everyone didn't expect it to be there
nearly failed with that combat encounter
but we really made it through in the end
alright so another 2 passed out man in
here I'm just gonna close this what do
you think he was doing in here writing
all of this what does it say wow wow wow
wow wow this is gonna open that outside
world here we come
I still think everything's actually
quite pretty you know if that's just me
but I don't know I think this looks nice
who are you hi there
hey hey we are we cool ah I was talking
to a statue excellent
where is water excuse me sir may I have
some water I'm super dying well this is
creepy
Oh Oh God No
what a terrible house that obviously I'm
going to explore further because it's
extremely intriguing ah oh boy I'm sorry
George
oh yes canteen nope I'm not sorry
anymore cool cool cool Wow everything's
going great
hey any of you creeps got any food can I
eat these plants let me see if I can
maybe one of the various plants that I
have is edible they'll be in here
hunger yes yes Jim Jim yes yes I will
take food please years that should do me
for a little bit off to the train
station okay
I thought he was creepy when he said
nice suit but now he seems fine it
sounds great alright yeah just go to the
people with the helmets and the weapons
why don't I just move here to head boys
it seems like a nice place to live it's
pretty chill all right wait in did I did
I finish the game is this what being a
pro gamer is like hi
not many people get this bar it's sort
of a taste someone who hold up what did
these [ __ ] ask me to do Oh give up my
turn it's fine I only had like an
umbrella and a branch all right you know
what I personally actually love arenas
and games ever since April the Lost
Chapters okay I'm ready
is it me am i King Arthur yes hello yes
all of my adoring fans thank you so much
for having me back there's always saying
I don't even eat food right now I don't
want to kill him no I'm gonna knock this
boy out
so this combat is fine is what I will
say so far it's fine
I see so if he's blocking then we show
them yeah he's on the ground get it yeah
get a [ __ ] I could if I can get out of
here
happy happy great are they gonna kill me
now is that where you walk is this the
part where you kill me oh no I'm really
allowed to leave oh no just give me food
just food
alright well you could do that I guess
Oh metal bits clan 700 we just dumped me
with dead body why wouldn't they
wouldn't they want to keep me fighting
when I just when I just did good hey do
you have food hey y'all got any food
okay
don't turn around no yep that's good
come up here I'm not a press V right on
him I think is anyone else authen when
you're trying to be stealthy maybe don't
tell people it won't hurt no I wanted to
put you on the bed can you just come
with me and we just see he's just sleep
you guys don't sleep like that it's cool
hat I like that hat Mike
oh okay well that was an accident I
didn't mean to do that I guess I go
rounds me oh all right
nailed it it's really I feel like I'm
skilled at this I don't know if you guys
have been noticing but like I feel like
my place in this world as off the king
of whatever is oh I got a shimmy bar is
to be an artist
I just sculpt unconscious bodies looking
look that's good
yes just one in every room everyone wins
we all just benefit from my odd whoa hey
girl I'm still done wall medals that was
easier than I expected it to be okay
this isn't what this looked like before
it's nice and bright outside that's nice
you got all these glass bottles which
means that I probably need to distract
some people yes classic video games
hidin in bushes and I can I do like a
good assassin grab where I pull you into
the bushes no that's enough I was hoping
I'd be a girl I can't go back all right
all right okay that's fine I'm pretty
fast I think I imagine enemies will get
a little [ __ ] someone else see me okay
if I killed you I'm sorry it wasn't
intentional what's this Oh am I supposed
to be going this way back to the Garden
District it's this right
I guess so what are you all doing what's
what happened to you okay it goes to me
also hello hello hello help help help
thank you did I just join a cult that's
how that works right you get help in a
time of need you're in a church suddenly
you're in a cult well what you're saying
is I look handsome that's what I'm
taking for you think I look cute yeah
this is my wife now I'm in a cult she
thinks I look handsome I have to craft a
torn suit why can't I just I don't have
legs I don't know nothing down here I'm
gonna check out what's in the cult
clubhouse what are you nothing this is
where we pray to Satan what what cult
leaders worship is it just the cult
leader that you pray to I think so hello
David
I got your medals torn suit yes screw
that proper suit no yeah that's what I
thought they're like oh no he got a
shitty suit oh I must be a different guy
that must not be the same guy there's no
way okay let's go across the bridge see
how it goes
why did you make that so dramatic why
did you have to climb up that look at it
look up weapons
I've forgotten about the revolvers Oh
spanked what one bridge now I'm off to
the train station that okay that was
weird
wait why don't I just want is it the
rotten potatoes that you all forced me
to eat I wish real life had that if you
can't figure out why people angry you
check your status screen that sounds
wonderful it's so I like that they made
this game they very good make some
dreary this is dreary this is pretty
like instead of having the environments
all look doc and messed up it's overrun
in a way that makes it colorful so that
it's not miserable to explore and I'm a
fan of that I guess the bad guys all
just have helmets cool can I be friends
with him he's my new cult leo oh my god
alright this is really rude I'm really
sorry but Oh what okay if you could not
do that I really thought I had him and
then he just glitched up on the walk so
that's not idea it seems like a good
place to do ought mm-hmm it's one of my
weaker works
I like that one no stay stay yes good
okay
and then let's put you right next to
this guy Just My Luck
what's going on there's so many dead
bodies everywhere and why are you not
posing them it's not that hot this is
interesting
we got puzzles a B D ad BC okay a D B
that's gonna be B right
surely and then see ya
and then jump out the window
okay
where are we going from hello-o
transition everything's coming up
millhouse Oh memories
okay okay up test yo-yos and then we go
this way yeah cutscene I think there is
weapon crafting yeah I don't know how
extensive it is though those definitely
an umbrella I can make that's very cool
but I don't have it yet don't make me
fight him there's a cricket bat right
you're always right sorry Marcus says
it's best if I keep to myself oh this
isn't the whole game talk to person to
get something and then break into camp
[Music]
all right well this is the place that
huh
this place is where you can get to where
I got to any the early access built
before I think it stopped the game or he
would like tell you he would send you
off somewhere or something I think I
just walked past him out I don't know if
I want to do that it's like a good way
to wait to do it up what am I supposed
to do about you we just walk Boston most
anyone seen you oh well can I take his
uniform
no okay well the five skill point is the
most I've made him up there's a hole in
the fence you're really just leaving
Yanks all right
this could be tough um what am i doing I
wanna throw a bottle ha
what is that what if you went to
investigate both of you
ooh oh that's not going to work
oh boy you really are staring right at
me huh
wow what a terrifying face you have okay
how am I getting out of here there are a
lot of them and a light so that way I
think we go through right there okay
let's wait for this light and this guy
to pass and then we'll be okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay we get
something to get over that way it's
climbing that's a good idea I don't know
I guess we'll find out I did it I can't
get through there I can steal [ __ ]
having that rubbish bin there are a lot
of them here so I guess I just keep
trying to go this way yeah it seems
right okay
I would have thought that red mean they
they could see me perfectly but I guess
it means like they're aware of me but
evidently he can't see me so I guess you
can still hide even which makes this a
very easy stealth game if I'm honest
that's so creepy did you guys just see
that dude [ __ ] smiling at me while
Michael Jackson sliding away that was
really creepy
stop it oh my god stop get back over
there again good I just threw another
one come on
get out all right and I'm just gonna try
and do this and really hope that this AI
is dumb enough that it works [ __ ]
it makes noise to just close the door
does that does that work and then I need
to hide I think okay I is bad did they
get in the building I think I shut the
door and they were like oh [ __ ] he's
totally in here [ __ ] can I hide
yes be high we're in why was supposed to
be so why don't I just find his keys
that's cool let's yeah let's just do
this and then I will end the string
[Music]
all them glass bottles yeah boyee how
did you even get in here
whoa [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] run
run you idiot run they didn't see me how
stupid my bleep get who I don't know
because there's so many of them here I
don't really want to fight one of them
because I'm worried I'm petrified a lot
of them oh there we go
how do I read that and yeah shits gonna
make so much noise where is that going
to be down the bottom the piano sheet
music not coordinate point that is Eevee
oh I guess I already pressed to be
alright I have to stop touch generator
do it
alright I'm still gonna leave this this
here cuz it is late and I need to get to
bed we gotta save this video game
because we made some progress save again
are you um
so thank you everyone I will see you all
next time wait